Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan, wir stehen wieder vor dem Salon. Ich bin zu spät gekommen.
Warum? Weil ich einmal wieder im Stau auf der A3 stand.
Diesmal 30 Minuten, das letzte Mal bei der Rückfahrt 60 Minuten.
Was ist da los?
So viel zum Thema Tempolimit. Aber ich habe es dann auf der Rückfahrt dennoch,
trotz all des Staus, geschafft geblitzt zu werden.
Das geht dann auch noch, naja gut, irgendwo ist dann mal 120 und dann denkt
man, ich versuche ein bisschen Zeit zu gewinnen und fahre mal 135 und sofort wird dann geblitzt.
Also wie gesagt, ich habe mich ja schon häufiger zu der Tempolimit-Debatte geäußert,
das ist für mich eine absolute Scheindebatte.
Diese ganzen verrückten Studien, die es dazu gibt,
wir sparen 700 Prozent der Emissionen, wenn wir das Tempolimit haben von 130 oder so,
haben mit der Realität überhaupt nichts zu tun,
denn auf den meisten Autobahnen gibt es entweder Stau oder Baustellen oder sonstige
Tempolimits aufgrund von Lärmschutz oder sonst was und es gibt ganz wenige Strecken,
auf denen man mal schneller fahren kann.
Ich bin heute, jetzt konnte ich ein bisschen Zeit aufholen, bin ich auf fünf
Kilometern mal ein bisschen schneller gefahren,
das heißt 160 und dann war aber auch schon diese Freude schnell wieder zu Ende,
als dann ein Elefantenrennen begann zwischen zwei LKW-Fahrern,
die dann etwa zehn Minuten das blockiert haben.
Das heißt, man kann diese Tempolimitdebatte führen, wenn man sich eigentlich
für das Klima nicht interessiert, wenn man sich eigentlich nichts mehr interessiert.
Er hofft, dann kann man solche Scheindebatten führen.
Wenn man woke ist meinst du?
In gewisser Weise ja, um das wieder zu erläutern. Ja das ist so,
ich bin für das Tempolimit kommt ja immer von Leuten, die in der Regel keinen
Führerschein haben oder kein Auto fahren können und trotzdem Führerschein haben,
was ja immer noch gefährlicher ist.
Und ich würde sagen, das ist für Leute, die tatsächlich eigentlich nichts verändern
wollen, die wollen so kleine Stellschrauben, die fragen noch mal nach,
können wir irgendwie neuen Namen uns einfallen lassen für etwas,
was so schon schlecht ist.
Wie gesagt, es ist völliger Humbug, sich damit zu beschäftigen.
Also die Frage wäre, wie kann man zum Beispiel dafür sorgen,
dass der LKW-Verkehr auf die Schiene kommt? Denn man kann ja davon ausgehen,
dass auf allen Autobahnen einfach die rechte Spur wie so ein Zug funktioniert.
Ein LKW nach dem anderen.
Und das war ja mal anders angedacht, auch mit der damaligen Bahnreform.
Das wäre das große Ding, womit man ganz viel verändern könnte,
womit man auch den Verkehr entschlacken könnte.
Aber ja, das wären halt die politischen Fragen, die zu stellen sind.
Alles andere ist im Prinzip kokolores.
Damit haben wir mal wieder dargestellt, es geht nichts vorwärts im wahrsten Sinne.
Ich will trotzdem noch mal, ich weiß nicht genau, ob wir es gemacht haben,
aber die, die ansonsten ja noch zusätzlich für Stillstand sorgen,
die letzte Generation, wir waren ja bislang uneins.
Aber nach diesen Aktionen beim Berlin Marathon muss ich sagen,
die Leute, jetzt ist Schluss.
Es ist absurd, sich auf der abgesperrten Straße, auf der Menschen rennen,
hinzulegen, um zu blockieren.
Also ich habe bisher noch keinen Ansatz, der mir das erklärt,
gehört. Ich finde es dumm.
Ja, es ist am Ende eine Aktion, die dafür sorgen soll, dass wir darüber reden,
aber das führt ja zu nichts.
Ja, aber nur weil dort Fernsehkameras stehen, das ist ein Argument.
Dann halte ich es auch noch eher für sinnvoll, fürs Tempolimit zu sein.
Das ist dann im Zweifelsfall noch besser. Ja, es ist ziemlich unsinnig.
Bitte keine Sportler blockieren. Vor allem nicht welche, die laufen.
Und das kommt jetzt von mir, obwohl du weißt, wie sehr ich den Berlin-Marathon
hasse, weil ich da mal rein da drin gelandet bin und nicht mehr rauskam.
Naja, das sind die einen Fragen. Die anderen Fragen, die uns beschäftigen,
sind, wie sind wir eigentlich mit Corona umgegangen? Und du hast uns hier ein
Häppchen mitgebracht, ich habe es mir schon angeguckt.
Du hast es zu zaghaft, Mensch, letzter Mal dir gewünscht. Ich dachte du spielst
auf diesen Karl Lauterbach Clip an, aber du hast Alena Büx als Name in der Liste gesehen.
Ja, Ethikratsvorsitzende äußert sich jetzt hier zu Corona. Ist das eigentlich
so ihr Corona Resümee oder dass wir kein Resümee ziehen können?
Da hören wir es uns erst an, bevor wir darüber eine Einschätzung geben.
Ich finde, man könnte den sowieso jetzt einfach kalt spielen.
Es ist Alena Birx, es ist der neue Zwanziger, wir machen uns über Alena Birx
lustig. Mehr Erklärung ist gar nicht nötig.
Aber ich finde, wir können auch noch mal auf die allgemeine Diskurs- und Debattenkultur
hinweisen, denn es ist ja Sonderbares gerade in der Welt zu sehen.
Kevin McCarthy ist nicht mehr Sprecher des Repräsentantenhauses.
Denn natürlich sagen 200 Demokraten, wenn sie vor die Wahl gestellt werden,
nö. Und dann braucht es halt nur noch acht Republikaner.
Und wenn acht von 200 rebellieren wollen, ist das halt eine Rebellion, die da stattfindet.
Und im Zuge dessen hat man ja eine riesige Diskussion, wenn jetzt die Republikaner
wegen Haushaltsstreitereien mit besonderen expliziten Verweisen auf Ukraine
Unterstützung solche Stunts durchziehen,
dann weiß man ungefähr wie der Krieg das nächste Jahr weitergeht.
Nämlich einfach nur noch mit Symbolpolitik. Also EU-Außenminister treffen sich
zum ersten Mal außerhalb der EU, um eine Tagesordnung durchzuprügeln. Machen sie halt in Kiew.
Um zu sagen, sie sind sich alle einig.
Und das war es. Alle fahren wieder zurück und es fließt trotzdem kein Geld und
keine Munition und nichts.
Also es werden heikle Monate.
Für die Menschen in der Ukraine sowieso, wobei der Frontverlauf das letzte Jahr
sich um keinen Zentimeter bewegt hat.
Und es wird aber auch für die Heimatfrontler, wie ich sie mal nennen möchte
hier, heikel, denn Semantik und Struktur wird so weit auseinanderfallen,
dass es körperliche Schmerzen verursacht bei Leuten, die an diesem Diskurs noch teilnehmen wollen.
Insbesondere die dann noch sagen wollen, die Ukraine muss gewinnen.
Oder die Scholz unter Druck setzen wollen, obwohl sie jetzt ein Jahr lang festgestellt
haben, ne, dann macht das nur mit den Amerikanern zusammen.
Da müsste man noch so viele Schippen drauflegen in seiner eigenen Argumentationsvielfalt,
das wird Schmerzenvorsorge.
Und für uns kommt es ja auch durchaus überraschend, dass es so eine große Gruppe
jetzt von Republikanern gibt, die sich gegen eine weitere Ukraine Unterstützung stellt.
Beziehungsweise das mit als Spielball ins Feld wirft, dass man vielleicht einmal
darüber anders nachdenken soll.
Also das sei ja vor einigen Monaten gab es zwar auch immer so Abweichler und
die wurden dann auch zum Teil medial groß begleitet,
aber die im Ganzen war man ja sehr dafür, weil das mit Aufrüstung und allem
gut zusammenpasst, was man sowieso immer von republikanischer Seite will und
dass sich das aber jetzt auch gerade dreht.
Also, dass da die Republikaner plötzlich den Ukrainern in den Rücken fallen,
kann man sagen, ist ja auch noch mal eine neue Entwicklung, die aber nur noch einmal zeigt,
dass es hier sehr wohl um so etwas wie einen Stellvertreterkrieg geht,
dass hier es nicht darum geht, wir denken zuerst an die Menschen,
sondern es sind irgendwelche Machtinteressen und es sind dann zum Teil Interessen,
die nur im Inland relevant sind.
Also Machtinteressen, die ausgefochten werden über die Ukraine oder auf dem Rücken der Ukraine.
Was einfach nochmal genau zeigt, in welch, ja.
Furchtbaren lager im soldat generell ist weil er irgendwelchen kräften
ausgesetzt ist die er erstens nicht mehr einflussen kann
und die zweitens ist nicht gut mit ihm meinen sondern er ist die verfügungsmasse
wie das thomas fischer damals in seinem spiegelartikel geschrieben hat und das
sieht man jetzt hier in aller deutlichkeit und ich bin auch sehr gespannt auf
diese verrenkungen wenn gleich ich noch anmerken will man bemerkt bei einigen
die ja sehr auf auf Scholz zögert,
wir müssen liefern und überhaupt ja, dass da sich einige ganz rausgezogen haben
und sich einfach das Thema gar nicht mehr haben.
Also einfach zu sagen, wir machen zwar weiter, schreiben, Podcast machen,
was weiß ich, aber Thema Ukraine kommt einfach nicht mehr vor.
Und das ist auch ein Klimawandel, weißt du?
Das ist ja immer zurück zu so Megaproblemen. Also wenn man sich so im Wege steht,
sich selbst die Beine stellt, dann geht man einfach zu seinem Lieblingsthema
zurück. Und da ist man dann ziemlich sicher, da kann man sich noch zehn Jahre
drüber aufregen. Ja. Also auf dieselbe Art und Weise jede Woche.
Ja, also das Tempolimit kann man jetzt auf jeden Fall noch durch dieses Jahrzehnt durch.
Die Autos werden größer und schneller, also Tempolimit kann man immer noch fordern.
Also wir haben es mit ganz schiefen Debatten zu tun.
Insbesondere, du hast es jetzt durch Zufall da schon auf den Punkt gebracht,
Wenn man Probleme nicht auflösen kann, sagt der Soziologe, dann löse ich doch ab.
Such dir ein neues, lass es Geschichte sein, nenn es Reform.
Zack, wird es vergessen. Und wir hören mal hier Alena Büx zum Thema Corona.
Eigentlich Debatte, wo wir irgendwie gehört hatten damals.
Okay, Leute, wir sind jetzt zwei Monate im Lockdown. Das wird uns noch Jahre beschäftigen hier.
Und jetzt denkt man so, okay, sind jetzt so zwei Jahre rum, drei Jahre.
Beschäftigt uns das eigentlich noch, Alena Büx? Schlägt mal hier so einen Nagel in den Diskurssarg.
Uns ist das ja genommen worden, nach dieser furchtbaren Zeit der Pandemie,
gemeinsam aufzuarbeiten und zu heilen. Und das wäre so wichtig gewesen,
gerade mit Blick auf die Jungen, die ja wirklich gelitten haben.
Unerwiderte Solidarität, so haben wir das genannt. Und ich würde mir wirklich
wünschen, dass wir da stärker hingucken, die Jungen stärker ins Zentrum stellen.
So, es ist uns genommen worden. Es wäre ja so wichtig gewesen.
Was ist das? Das nennt man irgendwie Past Perfect oder Futur 5 oder sowas.
Also die absolut abgeschlossene Vergangenheit.
Man redet heute schon über die Vergangenheit, nur noch in Vergangenheitsform.
Es ist alles absolut durch.
Und die Frage ist dann, es ist uns genommen worden, das ist ein ziemlicher Passivsatz,
aber angenommen man holt jetzt das Subjekt mal wieder rein, wer hat es uns denn
genommen? Also wollen wir uns das jetzt auf Putin schieben?
Ich glaube nein.
Weil Putin uns den Krieg aufgezwungen hat, haben wir keine Kapazität mehr für
Corona oder wer ist hier der Verhinderer?
Und wer wird uns denn in zwei Jahren genommen haben, dass wir einmal reflektieren,
wie über den Krieg diskutiert wurde?
Wer nimmt uns das denn immer die ganze Zeit?
Das ist dann der Klimawandel im Zweifelsfall oder irgendein neuer Konflikt,
der aufscheinen wird oder die übermächtige KI.
Also es ist sehr schön, dass eigentlich die, die ja sagen müssen,
ja wir lassen uns ja das nicht nehmen, sondern wir sind ja der Ethikrat und
sind ja genau dafür da, dies nach vorne zu stellen, zu sagen,
ja uns ist das jetzt genommen und uns sind die Hände gebunden.
Du sagst es, genau. Ist es nicht die spezifische Aufgabe des Ethikrats,
wenn alle Subjekte ausfallen, die nochmal eine Debatte anführen wollen,
zu sagen, schnipp, schnapp, wir erfinden jetzt eine, es ist trotzdem ein Thema, weil wir es sagen.
Also das ist eigentlich die Aufgabe, ne?
Eigentlich, dachte ich immer, dass das die Aufgabe ist.
Corona ist jetzt vorbei.
Aber wir sind doch eigentlich sehr dafür, weil wir haben ja noch eine andere
Institution, die eigentlich auch dann mal laut werden soll oder sich äußern
soll, wenn der Diskurs so in die schiefe Bahn gerät. Das ist der Bundespräsident.
Also das Bundespräsident und Ethikrat sollten ja eigentlich so eine Funktion noch haben.
Jetzt sehen wir der Ethikrat erfüllt sie nicht und der Bundespräsident auch nicht.
Über Gauck haben wir ja schon gesprochen. Wir spielen jetzt nicht diesen neuen
Steinmeier Clip. Man kann sich das anhören, wenn man will, muss man aber nicht,
wo er dann eigentlich auch in Gauk-Manier nochmal sagt, ja, wir brauchen eine
Obergrenze und ja, wir brauchen Rückführung.
Also der einfach diesen ganzen Diskurs nur noch einmal wiederholt und dann aber
mit dieser Sonorität und Seriosität von Schloss Bellevue auflädt und damit das
noch stärker legitimiert.
Und deswegen hier meine Idee ist eine Abschaffung des Amtes des Bundespräsidenten
und bei gleichzeitiger Abschaffung des Ethikrats.
Denn man kann ja einfach immer Ethiker zu Rate ziehen, die können sich ja zu
verschiedenen Themen äußern, Philosophen können sich äußern.
Da braucht man nicht einen Rat, der im Prinzip der Bundesregierung weitgehend
nach dem Mund redet. Und bei dem Bundespräsidenten, wir brauchen da eigentlich
niemanden, der eine schöne Ost-Tour macht und Menschen die Hände schüttelt.
Wenn man mal eine Feierstunde hat und dann soll auch noch die Nationalhymne
oder so gesungen werden, wir haben ja talentierte Leute.
Also da würde ich sagen, für so Sachen müsste man dann einfach fest Helene Fischer
einstellen und die kommt dann und macht so ein bisschen Germany.
Deinen neuen Freund Jay Shetty.
Wir dürfen uns das Licht halt nicht so dimmen lassen. Das sind ja die typischen
bundespräsidialen Ansprachen. Und dann hat man so eine Kerze, so ein Wasserding.
So ein Social-Media-Therapeut, der so ein bisschen was der Nation erzählt. Irgendwie sowas.
Ich dachte, ich hätte mir noch irgendwo Notizen gemacht zu Gauck,
weil das waren ja ganz hervorragende Zitate mit diesem...
Zu Steinmeier meinst du?
Zu Steinmeier, richtig, weil, wenn der Bundespräsident so da sitzt,
er hat ja wohl irgendwie eine Tagesthemen-Sendung mit Karim Yozga eins zu eins bekommen.
Und dann fällt so dieser Halbsatz, also bla, bla, bla, politisches Problem,
in dem Falle Flüchtlinge zu viele und so weiter.
Und dann fällt so ein, das weiß ja jeder, die Menschen. Ja, die Menschen.
Also, also, zuerst der Verweis auf die Menschen, und dann, das weiß ja jeder,
ich höre nur Trump. Ja. So.
Everyone agrees. Everybody knows.
Ja, genau diese Form.
Und das hat sich jetzt so vererbt in diesem politischen Diskurs auf Leute,
die dann einfach die Menschen, die Menschen, die Menschen. Das weiß jeder.
Wir alle sind uns einig, das.
Und da wird einfach gesagt, dass wir keine Flüchtlinge haben wollen.
Aber dazu heute noch viel. Ich habe mir gedacht, wir müssen uns noch mal eine Sache anhören.
Wir haben im Salon das Buch noch wach gelesen.
Benjamin von Schluckhardt-Bache, inzwischen jetzt auch schon wieder Theaterstück in Hamburg und so.
Man kann sich's anschauen, müsste man eigentlich, also falls mal jemand da ist,
berichtet doch mal kurz, wie die Rolle des Freundes im Theater dargestellt wird.
Dass man Julian Reichelt und so weiter, ein Umgang in dem Buch, das ist klar.
Aber Döpfner, der ist ja noch in Amt und Würden und so weiter.
Also das ist ja eine ongoing situation ship dieser beiden, von der man sich interessiert.
Wie geht das weiter?
So und Döpfner rehabilitiert sich jetzt einfach selber.
Er hat so ein komisches Buch geschrieben über den Trade, War oder Freihandel oder was auch immer.
Ich google nicht mal, wie das heißt und ich habe ihn nur jetzt kürzlich gesehen
bei so einem Twitter-Video, wie er irgendwie dem Bundeskanzler noch eine Frage
stellt, in so einer Podiumsrunde und sowas, naja.
Er taucht jetzt also so langsam wieder auf und zwar mit so einem Thema,
wo man so daneben steht und angeblich denken soll, also das ist so sein Ziel.
Ah ja, da dreht gerade das ganz große Rad, der nimmt gerade die Chinesen auf
die Hörner und berät Olaf Scholz dabei, wie wir jetzt mit den Amerikanern zusammenarbeiten,
um die westliche Hegemonie usw.
Aufrechtzuerhalten. Da kann ich jetzt unmöglich irgendwas zu Sophia oder sowas
fragen, die da eine SMS erhalten hat. Also er holt sich einfach dieses ganze
Weltthema zu sich, um uns vorzugaukeln, sage ich mal.
Dass er gerade an ganz großen Themen beschäftigt ist, die so wichtig sind,
dass man sich nicht um die einen oder anderen und so weiter kümmern soll.
Und ich war wirklich sehr erschrocken, dass er im Pivot-Podcast,
den ich ja sehr schätze, Carlos Fischer und Scott Galloway und so weiter.
Ich habe jetzt auch schon wieder so eine Mail bekommen.
Ja, Stefan, der Scott Galloway, der sagt ja schon so komische Sachen über Männer
und Frauen und so weiter.
Das sind, bitte gebt euch, wenn ihr mir Anmerkungen zu Scott Galloway schreibt,
gebt euch ganz viel Mühe.
Nicht einfach schreiben, das ist ja wie Jordan Peterson oder sowas,
sondern ich schreibe dann einfach nur, sorry, aber ich bin Stefan Schulz,
ich bin kein Redakteur beim ZDF, hör auf, mir solche E-Mails zu schreiben.
Also man bekommt dann auch flapsige Antworten von mir, denn die Debatte ist
ein bisschen klüger. Und ich sage das nur, um jetzt zu sagen,
in dem Fall war ich wirklich ein bisschen erschüttert darüber,
darüber, wie das hier, diesen Podcast sich entfaltete.
Aber meine Vermutung ist dann einfach klar.
Das sind Freunde von Milliardären. Da ruft halt ein Milliardär an und sagt,
ich will in eurem Podcast. Und dann sagen die, okay, eine Viertelstunde,
rollen so die Augen und ziehen als Umgespräch durch und lassen dann Döpfner einfach reden.
So, und Döpfner durfte hier einfach reden. Und ich fand das so gruselig,
sich das anzuhören, während wir wissen, okay, das ist der Typ,
der steht diesem Laden vor, der die Bild-Zeitung verantwortet und so weiter
und so fort. Und zwar seit Jahren.
Und klingt dann im Podcast einfach schlimm. Also er darf jetzt wieder über Journalismusideale reden.
Macht er ja immer gerne. Er war lange dieser Zeitungspräsident und so weiter,
sprach für die ganze Branche, war beim Global Media Forum, erzählt er dort irgendwas,
wie man in Afrika richtig Journalismus macht.
Und das ist ja ganz toll, dass jetzt jeder alleine auf eigene Faust und so weiter
angebunden an die Redaktion,
die ihn dann beschützt und ich habe noch so im Ohr, wie Döpfner damals sagte,
wir müssen auf jeden Fall unsere Leute, natürlich nur freiwillig,
aber die müssen dann schon ins Krisengebiet gehen, wo sonst keiner hingeht.
Wo ich mir denke, in ein akutes Krisengebiet muss wirklich niemand gehen.
So blöd das ist, dass wir keine News aus Jemen oder Afghanistan haben,
aber es würde die Lage nicht verändern und wir wären auch eigentlich in der
Lage, uns darüber aufzuklären, was da Sache ist, ohne dass jemand für uns irgendwie
noch eine Kugel an sich vorbeifliegen lassen muss.
Alles totaler Nonsens, aber das ist so wie Döpfner gerne aus seinem Elfenbeinturm heraus regiert.
Aber ich denke, ein Medienverband sollte immer eine gewisse Unvorhersehbarkeit
halten, unbewusst sein, nicht-partizipiert sein und kritisch gegenüber allen
Seiten sein. Unsere Rolle ist nicht, eine gute Idee zu advokatisieren.
Unsere Rolle ist es, kritische Fragen zu stellen, vielleicht unwillkürliche
Untersuchungen zu machen, mit investigativen Nachrichten und Schubsen zusammenzukommen,
Nachrichten in diesem Sinne zu kreieren und eine kritische Reflexion aufzunehmen,
was die Machtvollen in unserer Gesellschaft tun.
I think that is the role of media.
Die Bild-Zeitung ist unparteiisch und bleibt es, wir wissen es alle,
aber zufällig deckt sich die Berichterstattung ganz mit der FDP-Linie.
Naja zufällig, wir kennen ja die SMS im Wortlaut.
Naja, hier hören wir doch ganz deutlich, man stellt kritische Fragen und wenn
man hat genügend kritische Fragen gestellt, dann kommt man am Ende wohl zu dem
kritischen Schluss, dass die FDP die allerbeste Partei der Welt ist. in der Welt ist.
So kann man sich auch rechtfertigen. So, dann kriegt er diese Frage,
es ist ja ein Tech-Podcast, wie ist das jetzt mit künstlicher Intelligenz und so weiter?
Bedroht das den Journalismus jetzt, wo wieder mal alles und die Computer sogar
noch selber Texte schreiben?
Döpfner so, ich investiere ja ganz viel in Technik und hier und da.
Nee, nee, nee, ich muss jetzt auf jeden Fall eine ganz tolle Zukunft beschreiben.
Wir haben jetzt die historische Gelegenheit, all die langweiligen Dinge in unserem
Geschäft zu delegieren, die wir tun mussten.
Ich gebe Ihnen einige Beispiele. Das ist die technologische Teilzeit der Produktion.
Das ist, zu einem gewissen Grad, Error-Korrektur.
Das ist Translation. Das ist Layout. Das ist Fotoselektion. Das ist die Art
der Aggregationsinformation, die da draußen ist, und das Re-Writen.
All das kann zu Bots step by step delegiert werden. Und sie werden einen guten Job machen.
Ja, genau so funktioniert die Welt, wenn sie einmal mit AI überschwemmt wird.
Dann haben wir ganz viele Journalisten, die ganz viel kopffrei haben,
wie die Eigentlichen arbeiten.
Und vor allem haben wir auch ganz viele Leser, die ganz viel kopffrei haben
und nicht die ganze Zeit in so Algorithmen,
zusammengestückelten Timelines wie bei seinem Kumpel Elon Musk auf Twitter rumhängen
und sich die AfD unterjubeln lassen, weil irgendwer nicht verstanden hat,
ach so, und das ist jetzt der Original Diskurs, wie Elon Musk ihn führt.
Das ist gar keine verdeckte Invasion Italiens, wenn die Deutschen mit Booten
auf freiwilligen Basis aus dem Mittelmeer Afrikaner fischen und zu italienischen Hafen fahren.
Es ist so schräg. Also ich bin auch absolut am Jahresende Schluss auf Twitter.
Also ich hab da wirklich keinen Bock mehr drauf. Das ist so dumm.
Dann musst du jetzt auch zu dem braunen Himmel.
Ja, ich bin schon bei Blue Sky. Ich habe auch schon 200 Follower.
Und soll ich jetzt auch dahin gehen? Du musst unbedingt.
Hast du so eine Einladung?
Leider nicht, aber irgendwer treibt die schon auf.
Interessant, dass mir keiner eine Einladung geschickt hat. Wahrscheinlich denken
sie, ich bin zu wenig linksliberal. Das kann sein.
Heute Morgen gab es schon Diskussionen, weil, wer war es?
Ach hier, der Ronzheimer ist jetzt auch auf Blue Sky. Und dann war gleich die
Frage, ist das jetzt eigentlich eine linke Plattform, wo wir sowas dulden oder nicht.
Ich denke mir so ein bisschen, Leute, was für ein scheiß Diskurs,
ist doch bescheuert, ist doch nicht 2006. Es ist halt einfach,
jeder macht sich einen Account, aber wenn man sich nicht folgt,
folgt man sich halt nicht.
Aber gut, es geht munter los dort, finde ich irgendwie ganz gut.
Aber dann muss ich mich jetzt wieder auf so einer Plattform einloggen und alles
das ist, ich habe überhaupt keine Lust.
Aber ich finde, diese Zeit ist auch insgesamt vorbei von diesem ganzen Micro und so weiter.
Und wir haben den Anspruch, dass wir hier irgendwie Also jeder Teenager und
damit meine ich so alle unter 20-Jährigen,
die heute in die Welt reinwachsen, sind in irgendwelchen DM-Gruppen,
Whatsapp-Gruppen, also kennen wir ja Snapchat und so weiter,
wo sie genau wissen, wer das liest, wer nicht, wo es sichtbar ist und wo nicht.
Wo nicht. Diese Idee von.
Keine Ahnung, ich mache jetzt hier mal, ich promote jetzt mal meinen Podcast
an meine Follower und sowas, das ist eh vorbei, denn ja. Wieso ist das vorbei? Naja, weil.
Aber es funktioniert doch, also ich kann ja.
Ja, für dich, du hast ja auch 50.000 Follower, aber.
Ja klar, man muss schon eine Anzahl von Follower haben, damit man dessen Wirkung
erzieht, das ist ja völlig logisch, aber wir haben ja keine andere Möglichkeit,
als über solche Wege, zum Beispiel auf dem Podcast oder eine Veranstaltung hinzuweisen.
Ich kann ja schlechte Anzeige in der Zeitung schalten, halte nächste Woche einen
Vortrag an der Uni oder sonst wo.
Naja, man hat immer noch Instagram, um so was zusammenzumachen.
Genau, aber das ist ja, das ist ja das erstmal selbe Prinzip,
ob ich das jetzt über Instagram oder auf Instagram poste.
Ja, auf Instagram macht man so maximal, denke ich, also ich mache alle fünf
Monate ein Bild bei Instagram und vielleicht alle, jede Woche mal eine Story.
Bei Twitter ist man ja wirklich so, alle drei Minuten liest, schreibt, macht.
Das habe ich ja nie gemacht. Ich nutze Twitter vor allem als Ankündigungsplattform
und in Diskussionen begebe ich mich seit meinem Tweet zur AstraZeneca nicht
mehr. Es ist völlig zwecklos mit den Menschen da zu diskutieren.
Aber das es funktioniert. Also dass du Leute findest, die Interesse dafür haben,
wenn du alle paar Tage mal eine Ankündigung machst, dafür braucht die Plattform
ja eine durchlaufende Diskussion.
Also da müssen alle Leute die ganze Zeit, wenn es alle Leute immer nur alle
fünf Tage mal aufmachen würden, um was zu broadcasten, würde es ja nicht funktionieren.
So und dieses Prinzip, dass man sich so verlässt, dass da einfach immer die Diskussion läuft.
Aber bei Blue Sky wird das ja auch so sein. Ja, also ich finde es jetzt bei
Blue Sky gerade so interessant, weil ja alle, sagen wir mal hier so,
der innere Kreis ist ja da. Also Mick.
Ja nur versuchen sich ja jetzt bei BlueSky dann auch alle wie bei Twitter zu
verhalten nur soll es jetzt ein bisschen netter da gehen und dann fragt man
sich wie lange wird das vorhalten.
Also es ist ja jetzt nicht so, dass man dort. Ja, für mich ist das ne WhatsApp-Gruppe halt.
Ich erwarte da gar nicht, dass ich, wenn ich da jetzt was poste,
irgendwie tausend Leute.
Ja, weil du ja gerade erst da bist, aber wenn du mal zehntausend Follower da
hast, dann wird das auch anders sein. Also ich glaube, dass es...
Vielleicht bleibt sie einfach klein?
Das ist ja in der Logik der Plattform, also einer solchen Plattform,
dass, wenn mehr Leute kommen, sich das dann wieder in so eine Richtung entwickelt.
Also ich wünsche dem alles Gute und scheue mich jetzt auch nicht davor,
mich da auch noch anzumelden. Ich weiß ja nicht, ob das was,
das scheint mir irgendwie einen größeren Trend zu geben dahin,
als das jetzt damals zum Mastodon war.
Das spricht jetzt erst mal dafür, dass diese Plattform eher funktionieren wird.
Mir ist es aber auch, ja, also ich bin nicht jemand,
der sehr viel Zeit per Twitter verbringt und niemand, der dort in diese ganzen
Diskussionen da reingeht und von jedem rechten Journalisten irgendwas kommentieren
und retweeten muss und so weiter.
Also ich verstehe ja auch nicht, warum da Leute, die sonst für große Verlage
Bücher schreiben, sich den ganzen Tag damit müde machen. Also das ist mir nicht so klar.
Das ist mir aber nie klar gewesen, was die Leute da suchen.
Für mich ist ja auch Instagram eigentlich eine angenehmere Plattform und ja,
es gibt natürlich ganz viele, die da Profile haben, die so gut wie gar nicht aufrufen.
Manchmal hätte ich jemand auf Instagram, der sieht, dass er fünf Wochen später
ist, weil er offenbar gar nicht da ist.
Genau. Und ich möchte, also ich brauche weniger Twitter als das große Sprachrohr
für Ankündigungen oder so, sondern dieses kleine, ah ja, ich habe jetzt gerade
Zeit, jetzt gehe ich mal rein und dann ist auch was los.
Also einfach so sofort und nicht irgendwann später so. Alle hängen da rum.
Du willst, dass da ein bisschen schon wieder.
Genau, ich will einfach was schreiben und dann hätte ich gerne drei Antworten
innerhalb von einer Stunde. Und das ist, funktioniert auf Blue Sky schon mal ganz gut, glaube ich.
Gut, das große, große Rat. Döpfner jammert um die, es ist so schade,
dass die Demokratie irgendwie kaputt geht. Man kann sich das gar nicht erklären.
Nee, ne? Und wir hören hier mal Döpfner zu, es ist unfassbar.
Ja, Scott, ich habe mein Buch für meine Kinder verwendet, weil ich denke,
das größte Bedrohung ist, dass wir Demokratie verlieren. Das ist,
worüber ich mich am meisten bewundere.
Dass wir diese Grundlage eines freien und offenen Gesellschaften verlieren,
einer individuellen Freiheit von Menschenrechten.
Es ist von der ökonomischen Erfolg und der Abhängigkeit, die Schritt für Schritt
von Ländern, die sehr unterschiedliche Werte haben, erzeugt.
Und ich bin auch von diesem begutachten Ansatz besorgt, dass wir immer mehr
Firmen haben, die mit Bezug auf ESG-Standards exzellent sind und sich auf jede
kleine Details fokussieren, wenn es um Geschlechtspronomen oder was auch immer geht.
Und die selbe Firma, der selbe CEO delegiert große Teile des Geschäfts zu nichtdemokratischen
Ländern, wo Menschen getötet werden, weil sie gay sind oder Frauen wegen Adulterie
getötet werden. Das sind Doppelstandards.
Und das zeigt mir, dass Demokratie unter Druck gestellt wird.
So, das hätte ja eins zu eins so auch Mark Zuckerberg, Elon Musk sagen können
mit diesem Verweis auf Apple zum Beispiel.
Apple erklärt mir in der Keynote immer, was sie hier alles tun und überhaupt
und so, wie viel Leben sie retten und gleichzeitig wird aber alles in China
hergestellt. Mhm. So und.
Das ist so diese Silicon Valley verlogene Diskussionskultur.
Also diese Doppelstandards gibt's ja.
Absolut.
Die gibt's natürlich auch bei Springer.
Insbesondere bei Springer. Ja. Also das ist ja nun wirklich der Doppelstandardladen,
das hat man ja hier gerade gehört, ja, dieses Abfeiern von journalistischen
Standards, die dann sich in Bildarbeitsweisen niederschlagen. Das ist ja bekloppt.
Man hat dann mitunter bei Springer die ein oder andere gute investigative Story
und aber Gesellen sich dann halt 500 Aufmacher, die sagen, die nächste Flüchtlingswelle
kommt und wer kann sie stoppen.
Ja, aber es ist eben auch dieser Verweis auf, wir, also Springer,
wir produzieren ja nur Worte und bringen die unter die Leute.
Wir brauchen dafür Software.
Mark Zuckerberg auch, ja hier und da mal ein Rechenzentrum, aber sozusagen wir
machen ja nur Algorithmen und so. Damit tun wir ja niemandem weh,
vor allem nicht in China.
Elon Musk auch entsprechend, aber der hat ja natürlich dann schon wieder so seine erste,
also die, Berlin war ja die erste große Tesla-Fabrik außerhalb von Amerika oder China.
In Shanghai ist er ja zwischendurch auch.
Und ich habe ja immer so diesen Eindruck, nach zehn Jahren irgendwie sind die
alle drauf eingeschwenkt, also gerade diese, wir machen hier nur Software und
so weiter, dass Apple für sie die Schmutzarbeit macht, nämlich indem sie die
Hardware, auf denen ihre Software läuft, dann aber in China herstellen lassen.
Also da ist dieser verdeckte, ganz große Riss in diesem Silicon Valley irgendwie
drin, der sich dann bis hier zu Döpfner in so einem verklausulierten Ding irgendwie
niederschlägt und das ist so irre. Gerade ...
Ich weiß noch, wie ich damals vor zehn Jahren so einen Text schrieb.
Das haben jetzt alle Smartphones, Facebook schafft es nicht,
vom Computer weg auf Smartphones. Und fünf Jahre später war klar,
doch, sie haben es in diesem Werbemarkt irgendwie hingekriegt.
Die sind so abhängig von Sachen, die sie so sehr hassen. Also dieser Streit
zwischen Apple und Facebook insbesondere. Ja. Der sich dann in diesem Mark Zuckerberg ...
Also, das wird jetzt öffentlich ausgetragen, Wir haben ja auch besprochen damals,
es kommt dieses iOS Update, das die Werbung für Facebook schwieriger macht,
weil dieses wir tracken nicht mehr und so weiter.
Naja, aber das sind ja einfach die Konkurrenzverhältnisse, in denen sie sich
laufend befinden und das ist ein permanenter Krieg, den sie ausführen müssen.
Ja, aber die fängen diesen Krieg halt auf der ganzen Welt aus.
Also jeder Einzelne, der ein
iPhone hat, nimmt an diesem Krieg irgendwie teil, ohne dass es Thema ist.
Und dann haben wir hier Döpfner, der nochmal, ja, da müsste man eigentlich mal
den Journalismus so richtig sprechfähig machen, der muss die Geschichten erzählen,
wie sie wirklich da sind und so weiter.
Und er zählt uns dann irgendwas vom Freihandel. Dann einfach mal die Kämpfe,
die wirklich ablaufen, die Wirtschaftskriege, die hier wirklich stattfinden,
so zu thematisieren, sondern, nee, schreibt ein Buch über Freihandel,
in dem er irgendwie Olaf Scholz erklären möchte, Wie das jetzt geht,
mit den Amerikanern zusammen das Freihandelsimperium des Westens aufrecht zu
halten, um nicht gegen die chinesische Globalisierung.
Ja, deswegen ist ja die Bildzeitung zum Beispiel...
Völlig gegen Habeck, weil der ja die Freiheit einschränkt für die Deutschen durch seine Gesetze.
Zugleich aber ist die Bild-Zeitung der größte Fan von Annalena Baerbock.
Also es gibt nur positive Berichterstattungen über Baerbock und jeder Schnellschuss gegen China,
der in irgendwelchen Interviews laut wird, wird von Springer gelobt und bejubelt als gäbe es kein Morgen.
Ja, also genau, das müsste man sich nochmal ganz genau, man müsste diese Geschichte
mal so Lambi-artig nacherzählen, so Kraft.
Ja. Baerbock sitzt bei der UN und sagt, wir sind im Krieg gegen Russland,
Baerbock sitzt bei Fox News und sagt, China ist eine Diktatur und so weiter
und so fort, wo man immer so im Puzzleteil sagen kann, ja, ist schon sehr wichtig,
dass sie das auch mal sagt und sehr richtig und so.
Und dann denkt man so, nee, sie ist ja die Top-Diplomatin, ist das Diplomatie,
bringt uns das irgendwie weiter und so.
Und dieses Bild müsste man eigentlich mal zusammenbauen inklusive von,
oh Döpfner schreibt im Herbst 2023 plötzlich ein Buch über Freihandel und so.
Ja und bevor sie Außenministerin war, wurde sie ja von der Bildzeitung die ganze
Zeit niedergeschrieben.
Also da wurde sie als die Inkompetente, ja kann die Frau das überhaupt so in
diese Richtung. Und seitdem sie dann Außenministerin ist und genau diesen Döpfner
Kurs im Prinzip vertritt, ist alles bestens.
Ja, also wir bräuchten mal einen Döpfner-artigen Journalismus,
der sich die Bild zum Subjekt nimmt, zum Protagonisten der Geschichte,
um da einfach mal auch zu zeigen, wie die Machtkämpfe eigentlich laufen.
Nun gut, wir lassen Döpfner hier noch kurz verabschieden. Das ging natürlich
minutenlang genau in diesem Tenor. Und Cara Swisher macht am Ende noch mal so einen Hinweis.
Anyway, his book is called The Trade Trap, How to Stop Doing Business with Dictators,
which I think we should all do immediately.
And it's out now. Thank you, Matthias. Vielen Dank, Carol. Vielen Dank,
Scott. Vielen Dank Matthias, schön dich zu sehen.
Er ist ein beeindruckender Mann. Ich stimme ihm nicht immer zu,
aber ich muss sagen. Was denkst du, Scott? Ich denke, Matthias ist ein großartiger
Rollmodel für junge Menschen, besonders für junge Männer. Er ist seit langer
Zeit verheiratet, hat vier Söhne. Er ist professionell ein Baller.
Da sieht man schon, okay, also wenn das das Lob ist, sozusagen,
dass das Privatleben irgendwie hinhaut, also keine Notiz mehr zur öffentlichen Rolle.
Und er nimmt ernsthaft die Demokratie, die Menschen, die weniger glücklicher sind, als er, vor.
Ich denke, er ist ein großartiger Rollmodel für junge Männer und junge Professionelle.
Ich werde noch einmal nennen, dass sie die einzige Medienfirma in Deutschland
sind, die wirklich Antisemitismus-Aufgaben und Plädien umsetzen und die Leute,
die dort arbeiten, umsetzen.
Also nochmal der Verweis auf mit dem Arbeitsvertrag einher geht diese Präambel
gegen Antisemitismus, die jeder Springer Mitarbeiter unterzeichnen muss und
die dann auch irgendwie so gilt. Also Amerika ist unser Freund und wir stehen
an der Seite der Israelis oder so.
Nur Antisemitismus ist natürlich hier wieder so ein Schlagwort,
den sie da so reinbringt.
Das haben wir ja in der letzten Ausgabe vor ein paar Tagen behandelt unter diesem,
wenn die Sinti und Roma vor der Bundespressekonferenz sagen und so.
Naja, Antisemitismus, klar, dieser Kampf dagegen ist schon sehr wichtig.
Nur der war halt auch so ein Deckmantel, um darunter halt zu sagen,
da leben wir es halt mit Antiziganismus aus.
Und das Antisemitismus 2023 wirklich nur noch aus allen Richtungen.
Da auch der Verweis auf Hof-Eiwanger in Bayern,
der wohl halt einfach tagelang nur gesagt wird, es ist aber antisemitisch,
aber keiner erklärt es mehr, dass da eigentlich dieses, wie wir sagen würden,
das universalistische Argument, bitte einfach keinen Menschenhass,
also nicht nur nicht gegen Juden, sondern gegen alle und so weiter.
So und dass sie jetzt nochmal so verweist auf, der Springer Konzern macht ja
so krass Antisemitismus Kämpfe, also gegen Antisemitismus Kämpfe.
Aber auch nur einen speziellen Antisemitismus.
Genau, während sie gleichzeitig die Flüchtlingsdebatte und so weiter,
wird alles durchgeprügelt.
Und die können auch zugleich dann Draghi als Vampir darstellen,
der den deutschen Sparer aussaugt und so. würde ich sagen, die Bildsprache ist
mir irgendwie bekannt aus düsterer Vergangenheit und sowas, ist alles okay.
Und dieser Verweis dann, dass er dann Role Model ist von Skat Galloway,
also ich finde ja eigentlich diesen Querdenkerbegriff Mietmaul,
finde ich ja eigentlich gut, weil er ist, kennst du den nicht?
Ja, dass man also so Leute mietet, die dann das sagen, was man gerne hören möchte.
Und das scheint ja hier ganz offensichtlich der Fall zu sein,
dass man sagt, ja, wir haben die Millionen bekommen und deswegen sagen wir jetzt
nochmal, toller Mann, auch für junge Männer ein Vorbild.
Also wir wissen, wie Matthias Döpfner sein soziales Umfeld gestaltet.
Ja.
Nichts ist verlogener, als einmal im Jahr so ein der große Digital Tech Forward
Award auszurufen und den dann an Mark Zuckerberg zu verleihen,
damit er nach Berlin kommt und mal eine Stunde Gespräch mit ihm hat.
Dann ist plötzlich Jeff Bezos der Preisträger, der kommt auch nach Berlin,
kriegt auch seine Stunde.
Von Peter Thiel. Ja.
Also für Matthias Döpfner ist es total normal, dass er so Abende gestaltet,
in denen er Leute da hat und es kostet seinen Laden einfach mal drei Millionen Euro.
Nur damit er so ein Gespräch führen kann und dann glaubt er wirklich das sind
jetzt seine Kumpels oder so.
Und man würde wirklich gerne wissen, das wäre mal der Scoop,
der jetzt angebracht wäre, wie kommt er in diesen Pivot-Podcast rein?
Naja gut, er ist extrem reich und hat natürlich mit diesen Leuten zu tun und
hat auch da einen direkten Draht zum Silicon Valley,
weil das doch relevant ist, wo Springer sich aufstellt, auch mit Politico und
da liegt das auf der Hand und dann glaube ich gibt es jetzt bei so Leuten wie
Galloway und Fischer schon diesen Wunsch eine gewisse Nähe zur Macht zu haben,
also das ist ja doch bei vielen Journalisten sonst so zu beobachten,
dass man immer so das richtig toll findet.
Ich bin hier mit Kanzler, Präsident, wem auch immer.
Das ist mir so eine Denkweise, die völlig fremd ist.
Im Gegenteil, ich würde eher sagen, ich habe da gar keine Lust drauf, der Macht nahe zu sein.
Aber das ist so ein großer, großer Wunsch. Und der erklärt dann auch,
warum man sagt, naja, irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, was ich von ihm halten soll,
aber es ist schon, it's an impressive man.
Ja, also das hat mir nicht gefallen, dass ich ihn da so gehört habe und mir
alles weiterem unklar blieb. Ich möchte dann gerne erstens einen Werbehinweis
haben und es interessiert mich einfach, wie sowas abläuft im Hintergrund.
Vermisst du eigentlich Merkel?
Natürlich vermisse ich Merkel, die beste Kanzlerin ever.
Aber ist das nicht verrückt, dass wir, also wir sind ja nun wirklich keine Merkel-Fans
gewesen, aber inzwischen...
Ich habe einen Scherz gemacht, ich vermisse Merkel nicht. Ich vermisse sie auch
nicht in dem Sinne, dass ich jetzt sage, das war alles Thornton Merkel,
aber wenn ich so mir ansehe, was jetzt in der Union läuft oder auch was die
Apfel alles verbockt, dann ist natürlich die Alternative.
Also, dem möchte ich widersprechen.
Also, ich weiß, alle sind gerade irgendwie unzufrieden und diese Merz-CDU,
die macht ja auch nur ein Blödsinn nach dem anderen und so weiter und so fort. Aber.
Ich werbe nochmal dafür, für diesen Gedankengang einfach. Leute,
Geruhsamkeit. In der CDU sind nicht alle durchgeknallt.
Sie müssen nur ihren Chef jetzt zappeln lassen.
Das hat ja Merkel immer reingebracht, diese Geruhsamkeit. Also das war ja ihr
Talent und hat ja auch damit so das ganze Land sediert über 16 Jahre hinweg.
Ich möchte aber jetzt, dass die geruhsame CDU, die Oma Erna noch mal richtig
einlullt, mal kurz Pause macht. So schön das war mit Merkel.
Sondern ich will nächstes Jahr den großen, großen, großen Abschuss von Friedrich
Merz und Carsten Lindemann sehen.
Der wird vorbereitet, das wird eine ganz große Feierwoche für uns alle.
Ja, das mag sein. Ob die Union sich dadurch aber erholen kann,
also mir ist auch egal, wie das Schicksal der Union aussieht.
Also ich sitze jetzt nicht nur so, die brauchen wir aber dringend.
Nur ich glaube, dass es durchaus in die Richtung gehen könnte,
dass wir so eine Schwundstufe erreicht haben, bei denen die konservative Partei
dann keine Rolle oder keine große Rolle mehr spielt. Also vergleichbar mit dem,
was in Frankreich oder in Italien stattfindet.
Also ganz ganz bemerkenswert ist eigentlich diese Entwicklung,
aber ich will jetzt auch nicht allzu nostalgisch werden, aber ich möchte jetzt
eine Überleitung machen zu dem ganzen Thema.
Außerdem kann ich mir eigentlich jetzt mal erlauben nostalgisch zu sein,
weil ich nie zu den Leuten gehört habe, oh wir werden sie noch vermissen,
sie hat sie hat den R-Wert erklärt oder so ja, das waren ja diese Tweets ja.
Sie ist eine Wissenschaftlerin.
Das hat mich natürlich abgeschreckt und diese linksliberale Umarmung fand ich immer fürchterlich.
Aber das waren ja tatsächlich damals die ersten, die auf Merkel draufgeschlagen haben, noch und nöcher.
Denn sie hat uns ja Putin ausgeliefert und und und. Also das waren ja die,
die haben sich ja auch von jetzt auf gleich gewendet. Aber sie war jetzt in
einem Interview und wir hören jetzt uns das mal an und leiten damit über zum Salon.
Nein, also ich möchte dafür kein Verständnis äußern,
weil ich glaube, ich verstehe, dass man über manches verärgert ist,
dass man nicht alles gut findet, aber ich bin nicht bereit zu akzeptieren,
dass man deshalb Ideen und Gedankengut unterstützt, was für mich nichts mit
dem, was ich als Toleranz oder was im Rahmen meiner Toleranz akzeptabel ist.
Und wenn man sich sozusagen auf Kosten anderer Menschen, auch anders aussehender
Menschen, von Menschen mit anderer Biografie profiliert, dann ist das nichts,
wofür ich Verständnis habe.
Da würde ich immer dagegen argumentieren und würde sagen, man kann in dieser
demokratischen Gesellschaft wirklich auch anders seine Kritik und seinen Ärger
zuraus machen. Das ist verständlich. Es braucht diese Erzählung.
Es braucht das eigentlich schon immer.
Aber da wir ja jetzt auch in den letzten Jahren sehr viele Menschen haben,
die dauerhaft in unserem Land leben und noch nicht immer hier gelebt haben,
ist das wieder eine neue Aufgabe, dass wir sie mit aufnehmen.
Deutschland umfasst alle. Ich habe darüber auch mit dem türkischen Präsidenten
Erdogan sehr häufig gesprochen.
Wer ist verantwortlich, zum Beispiel für türkischstämmige Menschen,
die hier zweite, dritte Generation wohnen?
Und ich habe immer gesagt, pass auf, deren Bundeskanzlerin bin ich.
Pass auf, deren Bundeskanzlerin bin ich. Das finde ich ist ein guter Ansatz,
um darüber nachzudenken, Was bedeutet eigentlich der moderne Staatsbürger?
Und was bedeutet es eigentlich, wenn man da noch irgendwelche,
ja sagen wir ruhig mal, Wurzeln hat?
Aber was bedeutet das denn für das hier und jetzt?
Kann man diese Wurzeln nicht kappen oder ist der Schritt in die Moderne dann
nicht tatsächlich zu sagen, pass auf, ich bin die Bundeskanzlerin,
auch wenn die aus der Türkei oder die Eltern, Großeltern aus der Türkei stammen?
Und damit sind wir ja bei unserem großen Thema.
Können wir es schaffen, den Tribalismus zu verlassen? Oder sind wir auf unsere
Identität festgenagelt?
Lass uns mal gleich dazu kommen. Ich will noch ein was zu Merkel selbst sagen.
Ja, denn das ist natürlich ein wichtiger Punkt, was sie jetzt inhaltlich konkret
sagte zum Thema, wer gehört wohin und wer trägt für wen Verantwortung.
Aber, Angela Merkel und ich hänge sehr an diesem Punkt den Stephan Lambi,
das ist jetzt ihr erstes Fernsehinterview, den Lambi schon machte,
nachdem sie überhaupt das erste Mal wieder ein Interview gab,
also dann auf dieser Theaterbühne mit diesem Spiegeltyp oder wo auch immer er
sozusagen keine Fragen, sondern nur so Grundbegriffe hinwarf,
damit sie nochmal sagen kann.
Angela Merkel möchte nichts anderes tun, das ist ihre einzige Aufgabe,
als ihr Erbe zu verteidigen.
Geschichtsbild noch mal entsprechend zu drehen und zu wenden.
Also stellt sie sich noch mal als die große Menschenfreundin dar.
Und ich finde es super interessant und ich warte auch auf den großen feuilletonistischen Text.
Politische Macht, was ist das eigentlich 2023?
In so einer medial aufgeregten und so weiter. Wir haben natürlich sehr viele
Journalisten, die ganz viele Meinungen haben, die sie auch mit Vehemenz und so weiter.
Und dann sieht man sich den Presseclub an gerade, der ja auch wieder so ein
Shift 20 Jahre zurückgemacht hat. Also da sitzt ja niemand mehr von freien,
unabhängigen Medien oder mal unter 40.
Sondern da sitzen ja wieder nur die Standardleute, die da schon immer saßen.
Und man fragt sich, ja wollt ihr da nicht wirklich noch Wein trinken und einen
rauchen dazu? Also das wird dann irgendwie passen.
So, macht doch wieder einen richtigen Frühschoppen draus.
So, die kommentieren. Dann gehen wir so eine Stufe weiter und sehen diese ganzen
Tanzvideos der Hinterbänkler im Bundestag. Die auch nur kommentieren.
Dann gehen wir noch eine Stufe weiter und sehen,
Ausschussvorsitzende Europa, Ausschussvorsitz Verteidigung, Hofreiter,
Strakzimmermann, die kommentieren im Grunde auch nur.
Ja, die sind die Twitter-Heavy-User, die aber jetzt auch schon bei Blue Sky
wohl angekommen sind, deswegen scheue ich mich sehr da hin zu gehen.
Sie sind überall, sie kommentieren überall.
Ich hätte gerne eine Plattform, wo die verboten sind.
Also selbst die kommentieren nur. Ja. Dann rücken wir so auf die Minister-Ebene
ran, da wird einfach geschwiegen. Andalina Baerbock zum Thema Kinder irgendwie,
spielt alles keine Rolle.
Habe ich im Buchmarkt zugeschrieben, habe ich aber alles vergessen.
Dann noch eine Stufe weiter. Wir sind jetzt bei den federführenden Bundesministern,
die dann am Tisch sitzen und sich gegenseitig erpressen.
Das sind auch nur so Kommentare im Sinne von nicht mal wir haben noch Handlungshoheit,
selbst wir können uns nur gegenseitig mediale Blitzkriege so um die Ohren hauen.
Und dann kommt der Kanzler, der die ganze Zeit zögert, wie wir immer hören.
Und selbst die Fachkommentatoren, sicherheitshalber, haben ja gehört,
Frank Sauer und Masala und so, die dann ...
Ah ja, ich hab diese Doku von Lambi gesehen, der zögert ja zu Recht.
Der hat ja wirklich die Verantwortung. Der kommentiert ja nicht nur, der entscheidet ja.
Und Merkel gehört jetzt auch wieder zu denen, die einfach nur kommentieren.
Und sie weiß genau, zum Glück muss ich's nicht entscheiden.
Sie uns hier auch jeden Quatsch, das, was wir gerade gehört haben,
ist einfach jeder Quatsch.
Denn sie hatte 16 Jahre Zeit, uns ganz langsam daran zu gewöhnen,
dass wir eine demografische Schieflage haben, dass auf der Welt viel los ist,
dass Menschen in Bewegung sind, dass wir in Deutschland natürlich problemlos
nochmal machen können, was wir damals schon und damals ein bisschen falsch gemacht haben.
Nämlich, das hat John Philipp jetzt auch nochmal schön beschrieben in seinem
Rant gegen Frank Walter. Ich bin auch dafür, dass wir nur noch bei Vornamen nennen.
Frank Walter hat was zum Thema Immigration gesagt und wir können noch mal in
die Geschichte schauen.
Wenn wir eine neue Schicht an Migranten haben in Deutschland,
Leute, die nach Deutschland ziehen, dann können wir uns schon darauf verlassen,
dass die gesellschaftliche Stimmung hier so ist, die ganz unten auf dem Arbeitsmarkt einsortieren.
Was für alle anderen bedeutet, es ist Schwungmasse da, um allen anderen eine
Einkommensstufe höher zu setzen.
Also eine neue Migrationsschicht bedeutet für alle, die in Deutschland schon
arbeiten, verdienst mehr im Grunde.
Niemand nimmt dir deinen Job weg. Das war auch ein interessanter Hinweis des
Bundesministeriums für Arbeit, alle Zuwächse auf dem Arbeitsmarkt,
alle, zu 100 Prozent, haben mit ausländischen Arbeitskräften zu tun.
Niemand nimmt irgendwem Deutschen
den Job weg. Wenn Deutsche nicht arbeiten, sind das andere Gründe.
Was die Arbeitslosenquote anbelangt.
Jeder Zuwachs in Deutschland, jeder Job, der mehr geschaffen wird,
braucht einen Ausländer und wird von einem Ausländer besetzt.
Also nicht mal Menschen mit Migrationshintergrund in Deutschland,
die aber schon Deutsche sind, sondern nur die Ausländer sorgen für Wachstum auf dem Arbeitsmarkt.
Aber das hat Merkel immer versäumt, das klarzumachen.
Sie hat einmal diese Geste gemacht und wir schaffen das, aber sie hat nie erklärt,
warum es auch sinnvoll ist, es zu schaffen jenseits des diffusen Gefühls.
Aber Merkel kann sich in dem Sinne keiner intellektuellen Auseinandersetzung
stellen. Es ist ja auch hier, wie sie mit Worten ringt, keine besonders elaborierte
Weise, wie sie uns das kundtut, dass sie mit Merz nicht zufrieden ist.
Genauso war es auch bei vielen anderen grundsätzlichen Themen,
bei denen man sagen würde, passt auf, das ist jetzt so.
Wir denken zum Beispiel an die Ehe für alle, wo sie darauf angesprochen zögerlich
sagte, ja, mein Bauchgefühl.
Also man kann ja nicht als Kanzlerin sagen, mein Bauchgefühl spricht dagegen,
dass ich für die Ehe für alle bin. Da kann man auch sagen, ich habe heute schlecht
geschlafen, fragen Sie mich morgen nochmal.
Ich finde auch unter dieser ganzen, ah die Physikerin erzählt, erklärt uns den R-Wert.
In dieses Buch über Angela Merkels Kanzlerschaft, von dem wir ja sagen,
das sollte mal geschrieben werden.
Irgendwer soll es machen. Wir haben ja immer mal Material gesammelt.
Ich will noch mal darauf hinweisen, man kann wirklich ein eigenes Kapitel jetzt
schreiben über eine Physikerin ist Bundeskanzlerin,
sie weiß, wie eine Wärmepumpe funktioniert und hält uns trotzdem für zu doof,
um diese Magie zu verstehen und auch zu wollen, gesellschaftlich zu wollen.
Denn das, was jetzt über politischen Druck normative Vorgaben,
deine Heizung wird verboten und so weiter, machen, ist ja total dumm.
Wenn wir vor zehn Jahren angefangen hätten, den Leuten in der Sendung zu erklären,
wie dieses Entropie-Zeug funktioniert, um aus einer 10 Grad Umgebungstemperatur
eine 80 Grad warme Heizung zu machen.
Das ist purer Zauber eigentlich. Selbst wenn man es versteht,
soweit man es erklärt bekommt, wie es funktioniert.
Also man hat, okay, es ist Technik
und so weiter. Es hat irgendwie physikalische, ist immer noch Magie.
Und dass sie das verpasst hat, uns als Physikerin zu erklären,
wie eine Wärmepumpe funktioniert und warum es absolut Sinn macht, das zu machen.
Das muss da rein. Also diese Verurteilung muss noch geschrieben werden,
sozusagen. Aber jetzt können wir ruhig umschwenken auf unser Thema und ihren.
Ja, wir wagen uns in den Kulturkampf, beschäftigen uns mit den Woken,
wir lesen von Susan Nyman.
Links nicht gleich woke im Hansa-Verlag erschienen.
Susan Nyman ist Philosophin und legt sich hier mit den Woken-Strömungen an. Auf eine neue Weise.
Sie sagte auch ganz am Anfang schon, das ist jetzt nicht so ein Buch,
das Tiraden gegen Cancel Culture oder Aufrufe zu Überparteilichkeit machen möchte.
Sondern dieses Buch versucht, das philosophisch anders herzuleiten.
Und ich bin sehr gespannt, wie wir über diese Thesen diskutieren werden.
Ihre Kritik an Michel Foucault, an Carl Schmitt, auch recht kontraintuitiv zeigt
sie so eine schmittianische Linie bei den Woken.
Ob das so stimmt, das müssen wir alles diskutieren. Ich bin sehr gespannt auf, was du dazu sagst.
Und ich sage schon gleich, ich habe noch was mitgebracht dazu,
was von Jürgen Habermas, so zwei Zitate, die ich vorlesen muss,
um das noch einzuordnen.
Außerdem werde ich, wie schon angekündigt, über das Buch sprechen,
Die Zukunft der Menschheit soll es uns weitergeben, von Tim Henning.
Wir haben es hier wieder mit einem Buch zu tun, das Fragen beantworten will.
Der Populationsethik, ist die Populationsethik überhaupt etwas,
was man betreiben sollte? Auch die Fragen des Long Termism zählt es mehr,
was in Zukunft mit der Menschheit sein wird, als was heute mit ihr ist.
Also wir haben ja wieder so ein Stück analytische Philosophie,
aber diesmal eigentlich ist es das Buch, das man...
Vielleicht hätte lesen sollen, statt das andere. Wenn gleich ich auch da Kritikpunkte
habe. Weiter werde ich ein Artikel aus den Blättern vorstellen über die Misere der Studenten.
Ich werde einen tollen Roman vorstellen von Emma Klein.
Ein Escort Girl, ein Call Girl in den Hamptons ist unterwegs und driftet dort herum.
Adam Tooze hat sich in der Financial Times geäußert, wie die AfD zu stoppen ist.
Wie viele Billionen soll es kosten?
Es gibt keine Zahl, aber es gibt eine Richtung. Und dann hat mich der Autor
Thomas Wagner auf einen Text hingewiesen, der für mich interessant sein könnte
und das ist er dann auch oder der für uns interessant ist. Nämlich hat Theodor W.
Adorno in den 60er-Jahren einen Text mit dem Titel geschrieben, jene 20er-Jahre.
Er hat sie ja sehr bewusst erlebt, war da ja Ende 20 und hat eine ganz andere
These zu den 20er-Jahren.
Die waren nicht wild und sowas. Also ganz, ganz erstaunlich und wir können diesen
Text gut anknüpfen. Und unsere Diskussionen heute, Retromanie und all das,
hat mich sehr überrascht, dieser Text.
Wurden wir schon wieder von einer Medienmanie retromäßig in die Irre geführt? Gibt es denn so was?
Gut, ich habe Christian Stöckers Text über die erneuerbaren Energien in Deutschland
gelesen, weil es nur ums Optimistische geht. Es ist alles gar nicht so schlimm.
Solarausbauziel für dieses Jahr auch schon erreicht. Also da kann man mal so eine Liste durchgehen.
Dann in der FAZ, ich bin ja doch irgendwie aus allen Wolken gefallen,
Gundula Rosbach schreibt Risiko Altersarmut wie ein Leben lang,
wer ein Leben lang vorsorgt wird eine gute Rente haben.
Es ist doch alles gar nicht so schlimm und so weiter.
Was ist das für ein verrückter Text dann?
Ja, vor allem Gundela Rosbach ist die Präsidentin der Bundesrentenversicherung,
also da hören wir doch mal, was sie da zu sagen hat.
Dann diese Online-Recherche zu Krah und seinen China-Verstrickungen,
sehr amüsant, wir gehen das einfach mal so durch, das ist ja wirklich verrückt.
Und dann kurze Hinweise zur Mitte-Studie, ein sehr langer Text,
den ich ja schon mal so ein bisschen angeteasert hatte, zeigt sich dann doch
ein bisschen anders. Aber wir betten das ein in weitere ...
Also wie du schon sagtest, wir haben zu erneuern von deiner Seite aus noch periphere
Literatur, die uns da weiterhilft. So mache ich es diesmal auch mit einem Text aus der Zeit.
Super. Das heißt, wir sehen uns im Salon zu einer hoffentlich lebhaften Debatte.
Wer die 29er mag und sie unterstützen will, kann sich den Salon dazu buchen
und wer sich für den Salon sowieso interessiert und für die Texte kann den Salon
natürlich dann auch betreten.
Das heißt, das ist die einzige Möglichkeit, wie man den Podcast unterstützen
kann und wir würden uns freuen, wenn ihr das tut. Wie kommt man in den Salon?
Sagen wir das nochmal schnell.
Wir gehen auf die Seite neue20er.de, folgen dem goldenen Button und danach ist
eigentlich relativ selbsterklärend. Wir haben beim letzten Mal dieses Krautreporter-Ding.
Ich habe es leider nochmal ausgeblendet, weil diese letzte Info noch fehlt,
nämlich was kostet das jetzt insgesamt?
Denn der Ablauf war ja so, man bucht bei uns das Paket und kriegt dann von Steady
die Mail, dass man auch noch das zweite Paket bucht, nur das zweite Paket ist
bei den Krautreporter noch ausgeblendet, also gar nicht sichtbar.
Das heißt, ich selber konnte gar nicht genau wissen, was kostet das jetzt eigentlich
für diejenigen, die sich dafür interessieren, aber es ist ja auch jetzt hier
Feiertagspause und so weiter gewesen. Ich nehme mal an, das ergibt sich die
Woche noch, also wäre das Kombi mäßig, da wartet noch ein paar Tage.
Ansonsten unsere drei Pakete.
Kann man sich ja eins raussuchen. Ab 2,50 Euro geht's los und.
Das ist über Steady besonders zu empfehlen. Es geht aber auch.
Da ist das vollständige Archiv und alles.
Man kann, weil das nochmal hin und wieder kommt, man kann mit diesem RSS-Feed
dann den Podcast überall hören.
Man muss auch nicht am Desktop sitzen und den sich dort anhören und man muss auch keine Sorge haben,
dass man irgendwas anders machen muss als sonst, sondern man bekommt dann alles
von Steady oder Patreon, wenn einem das lieber ist, wenn man dort vielleicht
schon angemeldet ist oder per Apple ist es ganz einfach, da mit einem Klick
zu buchen. Also es gibt keine eigentliche Hürde.
Es ist kinderleicht. Richtig.
Und wir sind auch sehr froh, dass wir recht wenig Mails kriegen von Hörern,
die damit Probleme haben. Also es kann sich wirklich jeder zutrauen.
Man scheitert daran nicht. Und falls doch, einfach uns oder Steddy schreiben,
wenn ihr uns schreibt, sagen wir euch, meldet euch bei Steddy.
Und bisher haben wir nie wieder eine Antwort bekommen sind von,
die konnten mir bei Steady auch nicht helfen.
Also in der Hinsicht ist das doch immer alles ganz sicherer Grund,
auf dem man sich da befindet.
Wir freuen uns und sehen uns im Salon.
So isset. Tschüss!